hello everyone i'm simai dolaner today
i would like to present my internship
project that i contacted with omixlogic
fellowship program
at pine biotech my project focuses on
transcriptomics analysis of two specific
subtypes of the chronic lymphocytic
leukemia
in order to identify possible
therapeutic targets that are necessary
to establish
an efficient treatment strategy
according to american cancer society
leukemia is the second leading blood
cancer
with approximately sixty thousand new
cases
identified in two thousand twenty
leukemia has different subtypes based on
its origin
and the most common type in adults is
the chronic lymphocytic leukemia
which is the result of uncontrolled
proliferation of the b
cells it has very diverse biological and
clinical background
which determines the stage of the
disease
one of the most interesting stage is
known as
spontaneous regression which is the
disappearance of the tumor over time
with or without any treatment
since the spontaneous regression is not
a common feature of the cancer cells
it's an unclear process and needs to be
addressed
in order to make it possible to trigger
this mechanism
in other types of cancers for this we
need to determine well-established
therapeutic targets
which are the biological molecules that
have a specific role
in disease progression and can be
manipulated with external forces
that's why in this project i
investigated the mechanism behind this
process
to understand the cell's decision by
comparing the spontaneous regression
and the progressive tumor states before
going any deeper
let me introduce the origin of my data
sets
this data set is generated by a group of
scientists
and published as the bioproject in ncbi
in this study they compared multiple
samples from multiple subtypes of cll
however i chose spontaneous regression
and progressive samples
to understand the regression mechanism
better
in order to reach a conclusion i
followed three main pathways
first i explored my data by using
principal component analyzers
which allows us to see the variability
between the samples next i made
comparative analysis between spontaneous
regression
and progressive samples by confocusing
on
differentially expressed genes and
accordingly i interpreted my results
from the exploratory analysis i
understood that
there was a variation between the groups
so
in the first scatter plot we can see
that healthy samples and the disease
samples were well separated
which means there were significant
variation between the groups
then i wanted to see whether or not
there was a difference in spontaneous
regression
and progressive state in the second
scatter plot we can see that there was
an
improvement in principal components and
the two groups were looking
separate so after observing the
variation between spontaneous regression
and the progressive samples
i could ask the main question what could
be the reason
of this difference so we know
that genes decide the functioning of the
cells and by that
determines the identity of the cells
therefore
the difference needs to be in gene
regulation
since there are mainly two types of
genes such as protein coding genes and
non-coding genes
i continued my analysis with these two
brands
in the comparative analysis i examined
both protein coding genes
and non-coding genes to understand the
mechanisms involved
as a result of differential gene
expression analysis
i identified 870 protein coding genes
which are significantly based on their
peer values
and to fall change
after the selection i repeated the pca
to see an improvement
on the basis of variance however
according to first principle component
spontaneous regression had a lot of
variability within its own group
therefore i checked the clinical data of
these samples
but there was no difference between
other samples
so the difference had to be in their
biological background
that's why i choose the most diverse
samples
to compare with progressive samples to
see the real difference between these
two groups
in the means of gene expression pattern
and you can see from the second scatter
plot
there was significant improvement with
the well-separated
two groups this is the heat map of the
protein coding genes
showing the patterns between spontaneous
regression
and progressive samples it's obvious
that
most of the genes were upregulated in
spontaneous regression
while they downregulated in progressive
ones
in order to indicate the involved
pathways
i made an enrichment analysis
interestingly
although there were different pathways
in upper regulated genes
relatively common ones were related to
rna molecule
besides you can see the same concept
with the downregulated
genes when i made a literature review it
revealed that
as nearly 20 percent of cll cells do not
show
chromosomal aberrations scientists
change their focus to rna molecules
especially long non-coding rnas which
are deregulated in many cancers
and these findings led me to the second
print of my study
i identified 33 significant link rnas
through the differential gene expression
analysis with specific parameters
when i repeated the pca with selected
link rnas
i could be able to see better separation
between spontaneous regression
and the progress states
this is the heat map with the lincrnas
and it can be seen that
most of the genes were upregulated in
progressive samples
compared to spontaneous regression
since these significant link rnas can be
more important than previous talks
let me briefly explain what are the link
rnas
link rnas are one kind of non-coding
rnas
that contains higher than 200
nucleotides
and encompassed thousands of different
transcripts in humans
interestingly there are nearly 100 000
of link rnas
and these numbers increasing each year
with the new studies
lincrnas significantly function in gene
regulation
and in many cellular mechanisms as well
as in tumor progression
by deregulation they can regulate the
gene expression
at epigenetic or transcriptional levels
through histone modification
dna methylation or dna acetylation
moreover they can create hybrids as rna
proteins
to regulate the expression at
post-transcriptional levels
including regulation of phosphorylation
and ubiquitination
in cancer progression they can serve as
either tumor suppressors
tumor promoters or even can be both at
the same time
for some cancer types because of these
roles of lincrnas
recent studies highly focused on
identification of link rnas
as therapeutic targets since these
molecules expression
is tissue and disease specific this
specificity
makes them excellent targets compared to
protein calling genes
as my next step i made a detailed duty
review for the each link rna
and their sas mrnas even though the
detailed explanation can be found
found in supplementary table most
probably
they involved in several pathways
including tumor
growth metastasis cell survival and
regulation of
tumor micro environment such as immune
system
so here you can see three important
examples from top 10
significant link rnas ptpn22as1
is upregulated in spontaneous regression
samples
since the overexpression of the ptpn22
gene
can attenuate the cell that signals
in cll the cll cells may epigenetically
silence this gene
through the link rna ptpn22as1
and triggered spontaneous regression
therefore
if the upper regulation of this link rna
can be induced by an external factor
it could be a therapeutic target for cll
cells
next sneak rna is the pcf l1as1
and it is also upregulated in
spontaneous regression samples
studies show that the low levels of pcf
element gene
can induce spontaneous regression in
neuroblastoma
by regulating survival pathways thus the
linkin
apcf11as1 may downregulate this gene at
multiple levels
to trigger spontaneous regression in cll
is neuroblastoma
so upregulation of this link rna can be
used as therapeutic strategy
and the last name rna is the syngap1as1
which is upregulated in progressive
samples
as the singaporean gene is
epigenetically silenced in most of the
cancers
this suppression results in tumor
progression through
activation of the metastasis does the
upregulation of the lincrnas
in gep1as1 can knock down this gene
at epigenetic level leading to
aggressive tumor progression
in cll patients basically if we can down
regulate this link rna
syngap1 gene can be reactivated leading
to inhibition of tumor spread
and maybe it can trigger the spontaneous
regression
in cll cells as a result
these findings suggest that regulation
through the link kernels
might have a major role in cell's fate
and their detailed examination can
enlighten the way of discovery of the
possible therapeutic targets
in future studies each lingard name
should be investigated
to observe their functional pathways by
overexpression
and suppression studies in different
cancer types
to understand near certain roles
additionally next study which considers
these findings
should combine the protein coding genes
and non-protein coding genes
since these two groups reveal
significant results separately
their combination can lead to future
selection and determination of specific
pathways
which affected from each other lastly
as each research this study had several
limitations
that needs to be overcome to conduct
more efficient studies
first of all spontaneous regression
samples had diverse biological
background
which increased the necessity of the
detailed examination of these samples
furthermore due to this variability it
was hard to identify the significant
pathways
and as the sample number was limited
more comprehensive research is needed
to support these findings
these are some of my references and
before i finish my presentation
i would like to thank this scientific
community
for their endless support during my
internship at pine blair tech
i had a chance to practice my skills on
small projects
attend online courses which were
enriched with quizzes and hands-on
assignments
and participate in several webinars this
educational journey
was very valuable for me to enhance my
knowledge
perspective and my abilities as i always
wanted to involve in international
studies
i could be able to make it real with
this project
i'm really grateful to all of my
advisors who were there
when i needed anything anytime
i'm very happy to join this
bioinformatics family
thank you